c'est bien ça dont elles ont la pêche
ses bananes d'un bon jeu de mot ça vu
huit heures plus tôt piste lui car on
dirait une blague les cuistots lit car
c'est pas une blague vous fait
l'historique rapide de ce qui s'est
passé au bureau on fait des jeux de mots
avec mon nom de famille et add-on des
projets puis soly car ce n'était pas
censé être un vrai problème et puis un
jour un live sur twitter j'ai fait un
saut de gaulle ou si on l'atteignez
geoffrey une vidéo pistolet car nous ré
et vidéos de cuisine c'est exactement ce
qui est en train de se passer en igla
chance aux juan armée là est ce qu'un
grand chef a accepté de faire ça avec
moi et vous allez découvrir on va on va
cuisiner des bonnes choses qui sont
bonnes pour le cerveau mais c'est
vraiment une vidéo
je vais où je vais cuisiner voilà je
suis du grand spectacle en parlant de
spectacle la tournée de mon vrai
spectacle de mentalisme et du nord
continue en java est à pleurer les
aubrais gérardmer à bordeaux à genève
dans le 44 dans de 37 dans le 31 partout
venez vous alliez dans la description
mais pour l'instant je retourne aux
fourneaux
[Musique]
qui
donc je suis ton commis aujourd'hui
apparemment le commis de roanne de
cuisine un peu alors j'aime cuisiner je
sais pas si je cuisine bien moi je suis
le genre de mec qui suivait recettes
point par point pour moi c'est une
petite origine en fait je n'ai pas le
talent 2 milliards attend ça je peux le
remplacer par ça ça je peux rajouter un
peu pour telle raison donc comme je sais
rien je fais ciel marqué la presse croit
je suis un bon comics et les recettes
marche bien mais forcément je cuisine
les recettes qui me parle voilà après je
peux entendre le il ya beaucoup trop de
doutes à diabo introduit il ya beaucoup
de mayonnaise il ya beaucoup de gras
d'une manière générale j'aime le gras
écoute cette recette aujourd'hui j'ai
voulu déjà une recette simple une
recette qui nous prolonger un peu l'été
parce que on commence à avoir un tout
petit peu là la nostalgie de ces beaux
jours est-ce que je te propose sinon je
vais te donner aussi plaint d'un disent
pas ce que tu disais tout à l'heure des
fois je sais pas par quoi changer ouais
je vais vraiment suivre aux pédales être
moi l'idée de cette recette je vais te
montrer une colonne vertébrale je vais
donner ma tête j'avais vraiment yves je
vais désosser un veau devant ça et là
l'idée c'est de montrer qu'une recette
en fait après tu peut la changer il
suffit d'avoir le bon réflexe là par
exemple on a un poisson blanc pourra
faire un ceviche de maigres ont atterri
le maigre qui est un poisson maigre
comme son nom l'indiqué qui était un
poisson qui a une chair blanche qui a
une très belle image mais tu peux le
changer par n'importe quel poisson à
chair blanche tu peux travailler par
exemple du cabillaud tu peux utiliser du
lieu jaune tu peux t'amuser de marée un
peu et par exemple du rouget ton lève
l'impôt et tu fais du petit rouge est
comme ça en tartare sinon on est
d'accord que c'est une blague de
cuisinier tu vas et tu peux bien
déconner tu mets du rouge est que toute
une petite bien en fait ouais tu allais
clair tu devrais pas du tout ce talent
l'ademe bien on peut switcher
on va prendre ça aujourd'hui par exemple
là il ya la moitié des trucs je connais
pas je sais pas ce que c'est alors là
citron vert oui là tu as de la coriandre
un très importante dans les trois
éléments qui sont importantes dans le
ceviche qui sont la base de tout le
ceviche en général c'est coriandre
citron vert oignons rouges ok ça c'est
vraiment la base d'alleyras dit aussi
également quelques petites tomates
tactile grenat dire ça c'est un produit
ne connais pas un ouais bah c'est un
produit typique phare vraiment de la
colombie qui est de la famille des
fruits de la passion ok c'est ce qu'on a
on appelle les passiflores tu peux le
changer par du fruit de la passion si
t'as pas de fruit de la passion tu peux
utiliser des mangues tu peux utiliser
des très bonnes pommes que tu vas marine
et un tout petit peu dans le citron pour
apporter d'acidité des poires des coins
l'idée c'est un freak apporte de la
fraîcheur à temps plein ok j'aime bien
quelques petits légumes là par exemple
j'ai pris quelques carottes j'ai un
petit oignon nouveau mais si t'as pas de
carotte tu peux utiliser que des radis
tu peux utiliser nous on fait des très
bons c'est nietzsche et aussi avec des
de la patate douce ok tu fais de la pâte
alors c'est écrasé et c'est à garnitures
en revanche très bien une petite salade
moi j'ai une trévise qui est très belle
tu vois c'est une salade qui est rouge
qui est très très vif à l'oeil mais tu
peux utiliser de la pousse de moutarde
et de la roquette n'importe quelle
qu'elle soit ne fonctionnait pas trop
fort la roquette face à la roquette va
utiliser va avoir un côté un peu poivrez
qui va venir te réveiller à chaque fois
que tu croque dedans donc ça peut être
très intéressant après je veux juste
place et que je connaissais le danger je
t'ai vu mais c'est un malin tu as a fait
mais qu'un peu c'est tu me place dès que
tu as quelque chose comme ça puis on va
on approfondit slc salle et non c'est ça
ce alors même les biens et le piment sa
savaric merde [ __ ] je
sais que c'est dur c'est un piment c'est
très simple c'est les piments comme ça
que j'ai tout simplement fait cuire dans
une poêle et dmx est lassé des piments
jalapenos vers là j'ai utilisé des
petits rouges qui sont un tout petit peu
plus tôt parce que ça ça ça on verra ça
tape c'est ce qu'on dit sur ces piments
là non c'est un peu comme le péage parce
que tu payes à la sortie ah oui c'est
fait attention à la quantité vous
risquez de vous souvenir de moi très
longtemps là qu'on n'y a pas de fumée de
poissons comme il n'ya pas de cuisson je
vais rajouter un peu de livres qui
veulent rapporter de l'amertume et des
clients ça te dit si on commence ben moi
je moi je ne sais pas ce qu'on fait là
regarde tu fais attention à tes doigts
ok parce que les couteaux coût peut bien
tu vécu chez les deux oignons c'est le
travail du comice d'accord c'est ce qui
est bien d'être chef c'est que tu te
tapes plus jamais le boulot de merde
allez c'est terrible quand t'es pas chef
et que tu cuisine avec un chef c'est que
tu dis tu remets en question toute ta
vie là je viens de dire est ce que
vraiment vous assez bien les matches et
un oignon je crois que notre jeu fait
n'importe comment - l'asie michael tu
perds la tête ouais parfait et là où
pleuvent j'étais du bénéfice à monsieur
mais c'est pas franchement à côté des
gens que j'ai vu c'est quand même pas
très mal on enlève ce qu'on appelle là
pour les tomates donc le pédoncule
qui est la partie alors des as tu me
parle pas comme ça c'est toi tu devais
donc tu le vois je peux donc l'inter est
d'ailleurs tu nous a pas dit mais le
ceviche pour ceux qui savent pas c'est
vraiment un plat de cette fois c'est ici
qu'un plat colombien alors les ceviche
viennent d'amérique latine exactement on
le on les utilise un peu partout hier au
pérou il ya au chili c'est un peu comme
le houmous dans la méditerranée d'accord
en ce que tu peux créer générer une
guerre mondiale pour savoir qui est à
l'origine de savic et ou du houmous est
en fait chez nous c'est vrai que il ya
plusieurs théories il se dit qu'en fait
nous on mangeait pas forcément du
poisson cru mais après la guerre il ya
eu beaucoup de japonais qui ont migré
hockey en amérique latine et ça a ramené
au pérou il ya eu beaucoup ont une vue
du poisson cru a le goût du poisson cru
et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je voulais
travailler et découper le poisson d'une
façon qui s'appelle le tilt alito est en
fait le tilt a dit ou tu verras ça très
pensée énormément à ce que on connaît
comme un sashimi ok c'est vraiment des
tranches très fines de de poisson donc
les tomates juste des petits des petits
d1 il vaut mieux avoir des couteaux qui
coupent bien meilleur on est en
partenariat avec août au point comme
pour cette vidéo
et avec tomates point fr os arrivera
cordialement donc on met nos tomates
dans un petit bol qui vont nous servir
derrière allié à tartas quantité c'est
pour eux c'est un ceviche pourquoi 4
ouais là on va faire 4 tu vois j'ai à
peu près 400 grammes de poisson donc g
100 g de poisson par par tête avec comme
strates plus vite c'est incroyable
incroyable mais c'est pour ça que les
chefs je pense que ça va très vite pour
les oignons regarde je vais vous donner
l'astuce pour découper les oignons il ya
deux techniques on enlève le pédoncule
le petit cul cul on retourne l'oignon
dans ce sens là et l'idée c'est faire
des petites lanières comment sarah guère
cessé ça te fais quelque chose d'assez
régulier ça marche très très bien et à
quelque chose vraiment vraiment de très
nettes si je l'avais fait dedans tu
trouverais mon doigt là bas je voulais
te montrer la technique justement parce
que tu parles de ça c'est que quand tu
coupes 1 oignon tes doigts il faut qu'il
soit toujours aligné ouais ok le gros
doigts il va jamais devant parce que
sinon on regarde on se coupe toujours
derrière et derrière tu vas tout
simplement aimé ça et une fois que tu
l'as tu as même pas besoin
voyons là ils ont fait des paris en toi
savoir si ça marche et aux à toi ah
ouais il a gelé bien regarder faire
regardez regardez par la com il a dû
revoir je regarde pas ce que fait
non le plus gros c'est cuit non plus
réactif et
très fort pouvoir oxydant
mais voir une nouvelle ère celle là ok
donc l'âge pour lui
cela va être plus simple pour toi si tu
le prends dans ce sens là ok tu poses
mais voilà tout et après on doit en
général se doit la il est mieux là tu as
you need to what avançant des petits
pots taponier ok ton doigt ils viennent
là exactement et là tout simplement que
tu vas faire ce geste là comme moi là là
je le fais lentement pour accéder en
temps fou après 30 ans je suis assez
impressionné d'être quasiment aussi
rapide que toi quand même un peu plus
long à bagnères [ __ ] je les vois là
bas tu vois j'ai parlé de ma perte
serait toujours aux machines non c'est
annick et vraiment on a à peu près la
même taille aussi folle moi je suis à
peu près cinq fois la zoé garder pour le
personnel c'est
la
halle et personnelle et celle là elle
est sage non en vrai c'est pas mal du
tout je vais mettre ça ici et on va
attaquer notre poisson il ya plusieurs
donc dans leur famille décennies che est
allé ceviche classique dans lequel tu va
découper ton poisson comme ça on dit
c'est un peu plus gros que le tartare
nom qu'on ait le tartare français qui
est taillée à ses petits la bataille est
un tout petit peu plus gros tu vois
c'est d'aider un peu de cette taille là
et là aujourd'hui le poisson que je
voulais te montrer et c'est là où on met
ça met aussi en évidence l'origine des
ceviche c'est que on va venir faire des
lanières tu vois ok comme ça et ça ça va
nous apporter un poisson qui qui a une
très bonne match qui est qui a deux la
mince mais qui est pas à dur parce que
tu va taper dans les suivre dans les
fibres qui sont qu'ils soient qui ont
été un peu des coupes et si tu découpes
finement qui aura quelque chose d'assez
magique ce que proposait que toi tu vas
commencer à dresser l'idée c'est que tu
remplissent un peu l'assiette comme ça
que ça c'est un vrai repas cas demain la
commune oui mais bien sûr moi ça m'a
toujours fait plaisir d'aider les petits
jeunes comme toi c'est tellement
s'aggrave merci beaucoup et toi pour le
tout à fait une école de restauration
chez toi j'ai dans mon métier ont
beaucoup de choses en commun c'est que
tu avoues faire des études citées pas en
train de la de t'entraîner de pratiquer
sa et moi j'ai eu beaucoup de chance et
que j'ai fait pas mal de terrain je suis
arrivé à 18 en france inter et je rêvais
de faire la cuisine je parle est un
petit peu français et j'ai commencé chez
un grand monsieur chez pierre gagnaire
un des chefs les plus connus au monde et
j'ai réussi à travailler chez lui
derrière j'ai bossé au george 5 au
bristol et j'ai fait un petit passage un
peu chaotique par top chef je suis pas
très bon à l'époque que je finis dizier
10e je pense entre 14 hockey mais c'est
top chef ça te permet de de d'apparaître
un peu à la télé si tu es assez c'est
assez drôle sympa qui cite un tout petit
peu de potentiel sympathie sattouf des
portes et c'est un tremplin énorme donc
juste avec ça on a réussi un peu à se
faire un petit chemin est ouvert mon
premier resto à boulogne qui s'appelle
plancha et aujourd'hui on en a 12 et là
on est à base auto qui est le dernier
col a ouvert il ya deux mois et on est
très content parce que c'est la première
fois que je vois un restaurant
colombiens sur mes origines et ça me
fait très plaisir c'est la boucle est
bouclée est trop bien bravo pour moi
c'était ça on assaisonne regarde encore
en vrai pour l'instant c'est pas hyper
compliqué le mal où je parle vraiment
pour repenser ou qui regardent la vidéo
t'as pas de cuisson ontarien super
series oignons cas claque à tous les
couples qui fêtaient tomates claquettes
qui les coupe ton poisson tu le fais
comme ça bon vous allez faire comme moi
d'étranges comme ça pour la plupart mais
au fur à mesure il a dit on s'entraîne
et on va acheter à affiner c'est très
facile à super simple nos tomates qui
ont été découpés en dés ma petite c'est
bête que je vais juste évincé je fais la
moitié du flou bien sûr et ça c'est
oméga-3 c'est le copain du cerveau ça
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on doit à manger
pour que notre cerveau puisse se
développer puis si très tranchés santé
et puissent avoir les sens essentiel
pour pouvoir bouger en fait le truc
c'est que c'est pas différent que pour
le reste de ton corps en gros le cerveau
il va consommer entre 21 et 25 % de ce
que tu consommes donc c'est l'organe qui
te prend le plus d'énergie et c'est
l'organe le plus grave ton corps mais si
tu prends que des de la malbouffe des
gras saturés et s'est dit toi que c'est
comme ça que tu va réfléchir en fait
c'est le carburant nathan cerveau c'est
pareil il ya deux trucs qui sont
importants pour le cerveau c'est qualité
du sommeil qualité de la nourriture donc
aujourd'hui on le sait d'ailleurs on a
fait des irm de ça si tu manges mal ton
cerveau est polluée donc tu réfléchis
mal au sens propre du terme son
raisonnement est pollué parce que tu
réfléchis tu assez vite et dont on a
regagné fatigué et qu'on connaît des
périodes comme ça un tout petit peu par
exemple moi je viens d'ouvrir un resto
beaucoup d'activités peu de sommeil est
ce que les petites pièces de 10 15
minutes récupératrice bien ouais y'a pas
de petits gants si tu peux si tu peux à
un moment donné a jeté un dodo de 20
minutes prend le tu vois et tu peux
compenser avec beaucoup d'eau pour bien
hydrater ton cerveau l'aider à éliminer
des choses tu vas me dire ça arrange pas
et peu d'alcool c'est ce que j'allais
dire c'est que si tu dors peu alcoolisé
toi le moins possible enfin ouais je
fais tout en longueur et désolé mais je
vois ça je suis arrivé j'ai entendu
clean clean comme ça ils arrivent à
s'envoler les bouteilles bon on est
bientôt à la fin on regarde juste tu dis
peut-être tanchoux à tata fait ça quand
je parlais bah ouais je te regarde et
incroyable et eva si c'est une salade
que j'aime beaucoup parce que tu as un
peu d'amertume dedans - korian dans les
queues des coriandre ont beaucoup de
goût et à la différence du basilic ou ou
du persil les queues de la corde de
coriandre sont pas très très dur donc à
la mhc assez agréable et c'est marrant
là en vrai à prendre un truc bien que je
pense que si tu me files de la carène
dans les mains je vais avoir tendance à
me dire non non c'est surtout les
feuilles tac tac tac les feuilles c'est
là où il ya le plus de goût mais la
queue à une texture qui est super
agréable et qu'il faut savoir utiliser
hockey et il faut surtout pas isoler
cette phrase important ça alors là mon
assaisonnements je vais mettre donc la
coriandre les petits oignons tiens tu as
mais derrière et citron
voilà nos tomates aussi on va mélanger
dans une autre sauce avec nos tomates
nickel impeccable regarde zeste de
citron donc est donc le citron
bien laver dont les est en fait d'offre
à l'intérieur tu as le jus cannes
acidité mais dont la peau tu as les
huiles qui ont le parfum c'est là où tu
as vraiment des notes aromatiques qui
sont très puissantes donc on va déjà
commencer par assaisonner avec un peu de
zeste de citron tiens je te laisse faire
l'autre faire exactement stylisé ce
faire
parfait pourquoi tu fais ça tu vois la
latte à récupérer le verre si tu viens
récupérer le blanc ce blanc la house
également beaucoup beaucoup d'invités
donc l'idée c'est vraiment le bouger
elle rappe tu tapes tu bouges tu rappes
table tu bouges donc pendant que fabien
est en train de rester là-bas
parfaitement je vais juste rajouter à
les deux pincées de sel dans ma petite
sauce à base de tomates coriandre et
oignons métal crucell il croit qu'il ya
une caméra on va rajouter il paraît
qu'on filme on évolue bouffer gratos et
le seul truc qu'on a la bonne technique
ouvre une page youtube et du gouffre à
gratot sa vie l'atir ajoute une petite
cuillère de donc de la pâte de piments
tout simplement des piments qui ont été
cuits à la poêle un peu grillé et ce jus
qui nous intéresse ce jus a beaucoup
beaucoup de goût c'est mais thomas qui
commence un peu à lâcher grâce à
l'acidité grâce au sel la coriandre va
aussi lâché un peu de jus on va goûter
notamment histoire de voir s'il nous
manque du citron du sel ou quand tu
cuisines en général à la maison tu suis
trouvé une recette et tu voudras pas
assez et c'est très important goûter un
an donc il faut il faut être très vif là
dessus et goûter tout le temps tu aimes
le picon non merde on va faire un avec
piquant et un sens piquant je te fais
pas goûté ça parce que ça c'est vraiment
des far far bah ça pique un peu c'est la
cuisine colombienne tu sais nous c'est
vrai que le piment fait partie vraiment
des des assaisonnements on a besoin nous
on a une sauce à la base c'était le
biberon pour les licenciés alors mais
ses appels à qui mais c'est vraiment des
petits mois et de la tomate et de la
coriandre et on mange tout le temps ça
avec du riz avec ans mais ça tout en
nous ici on a décidé de ne pas faire des
demi mesures on en est vraiment appuyer
les goûts et ça et ce raisonnement
défoncé le client 8 qu'on avait depuis
longtemps nous on veut qu'ils se
souviennent pendant deux trois jours de
nous tuer non mais c'est bien on devrait
toujours ton restaurant colombien
ça a du caractère vraiment ce à quoi tu
balance la sauce un peu par dessus moi
je vais faire celui là dans ce côté là
et ça c'est du travail à quatre mains
soit c'est beau nickel on va rajouter
nos oignons rouges les oignons rouges
qui ont été découpées par fabien de
façon exceptionnelle à sceller bien
ouais ça c'est les tient pour le site a
donc je vais rajouter des oignons un peu
d'oignons crus comme ça ça ça va nous
apporter du goût et le croco aussi
beaucoup de textures donc si tu veux
fait le tient derrière on prend quelques
radis violet radis rouges et radis blanc
et on va venir les rajouter pour ajouter
de la couleur pascal plas doit se manger
déjà avec les yeux il faut qu'il donne
envie à sa place un plat il doit être
beau ah oui je voudrais bien quoi
j'allais dire c'est incroyable quand
même comment enregistrons mais des
oignons et une sauce comment on voit
tout de suite que le lien est plus
bordés
est bien moins sens du beau dans ça va
tu vas finir avec terra di tuor il va
être parfait je ne doute même pas une
seconde là j'ai rajouté une petite
carotte qui vont m'apporter non
seulement de la couleur de la machine
seront ils ont été achetés en poste à
sud du bien c'est joli atari st laurent
jeu ça aide énormément faut se dire que
là on essaye de reproduire ce qui se
passe dans un jardin tu vois tu as des
carottes des radis et à des tas de la
coriandre et cette couleur pas se
mélanger de mixité donne un plat qui est
quand même très très beau j'ai un petit
peu de maïs croquant c'est du maïs tout
simplement que j'ai fait sauter à la
poêle vous pourrez le faire avec du pop
corn ça marche très bien aussi de maître
du pop corn ont assaisonné de ce super
bien j'ai ma petite mais là n'arrivent à
huy donc vous pouvez utiliser et fruits
de la passion vous pouvez utiliser une
petite brunoise demande qu on vient
rajouter à plat ça s'ouvre regardez
c'est très très bien sans cesse de voir
il est incroyable ça c'est me rappelle
un film genre alien 3 mega
est ce que tu veux goûter le fils aliens
ça tu t'es pas obligé de croquer tu
traînes un peuple un boucher après tu
peux aller te l'a d'ailleurs un goût qui
est très sucré sucré très bon dieu
j'adore sa main donc là je vais en
rajouter un petit peu comme ça partout
ça va m'apporter un peu de croquant et
se cote est à utah des notes qui sont
très exotique
le fruit commencé à l'interviewer j'ai
vraiment l'impression que c'est un truc
qui vient pas de terre ça pousse ou
amérique latine et en amérique latine on
a un peu en thaïlande tu as vraiment sur
les sur la ligne de l'équateur contades
et des températures un peu tropicale la
coriandre apparemment il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'aiment pas la commande et ça
serait quelque chose de génétique ah
ouais en fait dans la langue dans le
palais y aurait quelque chose qui le
refusent qu'ils refusent et du coin
c'est ça marche pas on le regarde j'ai
rajouté ma petite couronne comme ça je
vais finir avec un filet d'huile d'olive
faut que tu finisses le tien mais qu'il
ya disons que moi à regarder la vie
l'istat coriandre des carottes en fait
rien fait je te relire il regarde bien
venue pour les vacances moi j'étais venu
pour un poste je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est mort alors est-ce que
c'est pas beau ça et c'est très joli on
est d'accord ou l'aquitaine plus
généreuses mais ça
valait un peu plus fatigué mais elle
passe mais je trouve ça très bien
franchement tu as très bien bossé tu
veux goûter bien joué à la sauce d'un
goûter je vais te voir goûter la sauce
puissance ça c'est celle qui est
piquante tu peux oui
regardez moi ce sourire pervers qu'il a
là
où ça me défonce la bouche en inquiète
pas il n'y a pas de problème j'étais en
train de voir à quel point ayé voilà là
j'ai conscience d'avoir un naufrage là
je sais exactement sur quelle cm km
et là en fait je me rends compte que je
n'ai pas du tout les yeux secs ne
vraiment très humide très très vide
alors désolé fois les petits bleus comme
ça tu le comité ouais ouais moi je n'ai
jamais eu je suis vacciné au piment mais
tout va bien on va goûter le voyage le
plat fini alors qu'est ce que ça dit
très bon
ça c'est super bon c'est la fraîcheur en
vrai tu prépares salalah ont fait une
vidéo et tout mais tu te prépares ça la
maison en 15 minutes à leysin savard et
rousset hyper vite tu poses ça tu peux
dresser un peu en avance dernière minute
tu rajoute un peu de citron pour que ce
soit bien frais trop cool et c'est
génial tu vas quand tu reçois en plus tu
fais des grandes assiettes si tu veux tu
poses ça au milieu de la table et là tu
partages études régal ça c'est c'est la
même vidéo du temps mais on sait que moi
je mange en fait
j'ai abouti au mongol de cette vidéo on
va avoir un très bon plat bon les
équipes c'est avec vous que maintenant
s'habituer de maigres
grenadine prévis ce maïs tomates et
corriger s'il en tricot et ceviche de
merde qui l'est plus c'est presque le
même plus entrer l'eau c'est dur avec
toi il est très beau merci juan de nous
avoir accueillis pour un port ses
cuistots licka en vrai c'était trop bien
ça répondait au truc en plus de se dire
tout le monde en fait de cuisiner il ya
ce truc de tout le monde à un livre à
écrire tout le monde peut cuisiner tout
non thomas schaaf en vraie tombe pile
expérimente pas c'est c est un truc de
rassurant de se dire regarde c'est un
chef il te dit ça c'est ok et c'est pas
dur à faire et c'est vrai c'est pas
compliqué à faire mais si vous le faites
pas aussi joli chez ou c'est pas grave
si voir c'est pas grave du tout pour moi
la cuisine la table et l'assiette doit
être du plaisir et quand tu me disais je
suis au pied de la lettre les recettes
bain et c'est vrai mais en vrai ça c'est
génial mais quand tu mets un peu de
passion et que tu kiffes et a envie de
recevoir avec amour je pense que la
personne qui vient leur sens et et
assiettes seront délicieuses donc il
faut pas avoir peur il faut mettre un
peu la main à la pâte tu vois j'ai un
truc de méritocratie si vous avez plus
affolants levé car j'ai l'impression que
si c'est pas compliqué ce que je vais
cuisiner alors c'est que j'ai pas
vraiment cuisiner pour la personne qui
l'a alors que en vrai des fois les
choses les plus simples c'est celle qui
rend le plus de succès merci beaucoup
juan merci à toi à bientôt tchèque et
bon appétit donc liste nikkei business
et pas un one shot c'est un projet que
je vais continuer parce que c'est un
fake la douve vraiment et je vais pas
continuer sur youtube peut-être je
referai des vidéos christoly car sur
youtube si ça vous plaît parce que moi
j'ai adoré faire ça mais j'ai vraiment
lancé un compte instagram qui s'appelle
christoly cas on n'est pas beaucoup
dessus c'est ça c'est @ christoly car
rejoignez moi et je fais du vrai contenu
de cuisine dessus on dirait du second
degré tout le temps mais c'est vraiment
loin du premier degré donc aujourd'hui
moins sûre christoly car vous mais aussi
l'arobase de roanne armella et suivez le
sur instagram il fait beaucoup de
contenu et puis surtout si vous avez
l'occasion d'aller manger dans l'un de
ses restaurants genre le bazar tôt ou un
autre n'hésitez pas c'est vraiment
délicieux merci à lui de m'avoir
accueillie pour ce délire merci à vous
d'avoir suivi ce délire là si vous êtes
jusqu'à cet endroit là de l'avis des
auditeurs [ __ ] les bananas non
commentaire
la prochaine vidéo c'est vendredi
prochain ce sera un casse-tête glace et
on est plus sur ce qu'on connaît un vous
et moi et là je vous mets deux autres
vidéos ici c'est un autre casse-tête la
lupi box et là c'est le matière grise 11
le dernier épisode de la saison une
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao [ __ ] les bananes